qu'est-ce qu'on rencontre dans les
égouts
je dirais de la merde
beauté ceinturée foulard autour du cou
pour se protéger des rats et des
cloportes les égoutiers vont rester 6h
sous terre leur travail consiste à
pousser sable et déchets des petits
égouts vers de grands collecteurs où là
il se serviront de bateau van pour curé
l'odeur est à soutenable l'air rare les
pieds glissent le long de la fosse le
bateau est là tapis dans l'ombre avant
la manœuvre on nettoie les baffes tout
est fait à la main dans les égouts seule
énergie employée la force des eaux qu'il
s'agit de contenir par une vanne puis de
relâcher pour entraîner un peu plus loin
sable et déchets
[Applaudissements]
est quand même assez assez importante de
façon à récupérer le plan d'eau alors
l'eau va monter assez haut derrière
pratiquement d'ailleurs on peut vous
pouvez voir là que quand on est comme ça
toutes les saloperies qui peut y avoir
sur la vanne c'est parce que c'est le
plan d'eau qui se qui s'accumule
derrière et qui laisse un stock de
saloperie derrière comme ça
bon est-ce que c'est un métier dangereux
ici
là il doit y avoir quelque chose qui se
passe en surface et notre camarade qui
fait le garderie
et il faut absolument qu'on monte très
vite ça pourrait très bien être un orage
et à partir de ce moment on a plus que
trois minutes pour monter
est-ce que vous avez des problèmes de
recrutement les problèmes de recrutement
tu sais c'est un peu c'est un peu en
famille chez nous c'est de père en fils
c'est de
cousins neveux c'est un peu comme ça
c'est la grande famille les égouts il
était temps qu'on monte seule condition
pour être égouttier être français
[Musique]
l'odeur est tenace elle remplit tous les
vêtements la voiture
reste sur nous de deux ou trois jours
mais le plus grave c'est ce que l'on
respire à cause des versements en
clandestin tel que les acides et les
Tricolores ceux qui provoquent chez nous
d'ailleurs pas mal de maladies
professionnelles on peut compter à
l'heure actuelle 2 à 3 enfin environ
deux un égoutiers sur deux qui est en
arrêt de travail pour des maladies
professionnelles
et c'est pour de meilleures conditions
de travail une augmentation de salaire
que près du pont Mirabeau coule dans la
Seine en ce moment une partie des eaux
sales de l'usine occupée d'Auteuil
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on rencontre dans les
égouts
je dirais de la merde
[Musique]
on rencontre les dessous de la ville à
savoir qu'on peut on y trouve tous les
déchets urbains qu'on puisse y trouver
c'est le reflet de la population
nantaise vu par le dessous
[Musique]
les gens sont parfois un peu
inconscients on y retrouve n'importe
quoi tout et n'importe quoi
ils sont 55 à travailler dans les égouts
municipaux nantais pas de repère pas de
plaque de rue dans ces ouvrages qui
datent pour les uns du début du siècle
pour les autres d'après-guerre 630 km de
canalisation souterraine dotée de 7
déversoires d'orages automatisés quand
le système est unitaire mêlant ainsi au
pluvial et eaux usé les égouts vont dans
les stations d'épuration quand il est
séparatif ce livrons les eaux usées le
danger intervient lui en cas de gros
orages où l'on se voit alors directement
déversé dans un cours d'eau
est-ce que c'est dangereux
tout travail
un peu plus que d'autres et bon bien sûr
surtout en fonction du temps
alors faut toujours quelqu'un à
proximité d'un regard pour signaler si
toutefois il vient panora je des choses
comme ça et en plus les pollutions qui
malheureusement maintenant sont très
fréquentes je crois qu'on craint le plus
comme on jette des rejets toxiques je
crois
Roger toxique qui vont s'attaquer à la
santé des égoutiers aux émanations gaz
les émanations gazeuses qui vont en
résulter et également des rejets de
matières inflammable par exemple on a vu
plusieurs fois des matières
inflammatables qui risquaient d'amener
un danger d'explosion dans le réseau il
y a les hydrocarbures également qui sont
très gênants qui nous gênent chez la
station d'épuration
armée de ballets de crochets de jets à
très forte pression pour décaper les
canalisations et de lampe
anti-déflagrante à cause des risques de
gaz c'est véritables mineurs des égouts
sont médicalement très surveillés
examensant tous les six mois outre ce
contrôle médical les égoutiers
bénéficient d'une prime d'insalubrité et
de la retraite dès l'âge de 50 ans des
hommes qui travaillent dans l'ombre et
qui sont au combien indispensables
[Musique]